Hello and welcome to
YouTube Behind the Scenes.
My name is Matias Molinas and
I'm a Google Developer Expert
for YouTube APIs.
In this lesson
we are going to see
how to manage player events
and change states
in the iFrame Player,
as well as the Flash Player,
using iFrame, Flash
and JavaScript APIs.
We are going to look at
real cases that use these APIs
and how they use them.
It is worth mentioning
that until 2010
there was only Flash Player.
Now we have new devices,
like iPad and iPhone,
that can not support Flash.
YouTube provides us with
a new API, the iFrame,
that chooses,
according to the capabilities
of the client's device,
whether to use Flash Player
or an HTML5 Player.
This will also depend on
the format of the videos.
JavaScript support
is also added to the iFrame API,
converting it
into an alternative
for developers
that used to use
Flash Player
and the JavaScript API.
As a result,
we now have
the Flash Player API,
the JavaScript API,
used to control
Flash Player
in it's embedded version
and Chromeless,
and the new iFrame API,
with JavaScript support,
to control the player.
Are you ready?
Let's begin!
THE BEST OPTION FOR THE WEB:
THE iFRAME API
The iFrame API allows
the player to be embedded
in a web page and controlled
through JavaScript.
Unlike the Flash API,
where we embed a Flash object,
in the iFrame API we include
the player in an iFrame
that can communicate
with the page that includes it.
This way there's
a lot more flexibility
than with the Flash API
and the JavaScript API,
since it allows
YouTube to decide
if it uploads Flash Player
or HTML5 Player,
which most portable devices
can support.
Using JavaScript,
you can download videos,
play videos,
pause them, adjust the volume,
and obtain information
for the video being watched.
}STEP 1
CREATE THE PLAYER
There are some important
details to remember.
The iFrame API uses
an HTML5 characteristic
called postMessage.
Browsers like
Internet Explorer 7
can not support it.
Also keep in mind
that the minimum size
for the player
has to be 200x200 pixels.
For any web page
that uses the iFrame Player,
you should implement
the JavaScript function called
when the JavaScript library
has finished downloading.
You should also
create the players
you're going to use
on your page in this function.
}STEP 2 -KNOW THE STATE
AND CONTROL THE PLAYER
Now let's see a complete example
of how to download a video,
have it start to play
automatically,
keep playing for 6 seconds,
and stop.
}STEP 3
HOW IT WORKS
Let's go through a step-by-step
of the example in Chrome.
We see that the dome
is modified in the code
to download the library
asynchronously.
This is the form
supported by most browsers.
Once the library downloads,
we create an iFrame Player,
where there used to be a dip.
We do this
in the function called
when the library downloads.
We are going to assign
the player a global variable
in this function.
The onPlayerReady function
will come up
when the onReady event
is launched.
We specify that the player
should start playing the video
when it's ready
in this function.
The API will call
onPlayerStateChange
when the state of the player
is changed.
This is when we push play,
when we push pause,
and when the video
stops playing.
This function is implemented,
when the state is 1
or when it's playing,
the player should play
for 6 seconds
and then call stopVideo
to stop playing.
THE FLASH API
Now we will look at the AC3
Flash API of the YouTube Player.
This API allows you to download
the Flash Player
to your Flash application
and control it
from the Flash application.
You will also be able to use it
in Chromeless mode,
where you can define
your own controls
and control it
from your Flash application.
The calls you can make
with the API
are Play, Pause, Volume,
and all the functions
we've seen for the player.
The Actionscript API
will activate
when you download the player
in another SWF.
To use it, you will need
Flash 10.1 or higher installed
and remember that the minimum
measurements for the player
are 200x200 pixels.
Other than using
the Actionscript API,
you can also use
the parameters we saw
in the prior lesson
to personalize the player.
We will look at some of the
basic aspects of the Flash API
in the following steps.
}STEP 1
CHROMELESS PLAYER
Let's see the URL you should use
to download
the Chromeless Player
to your application.
If you try downloading this URL
in a browser,
you will see it downloads
Flash Player with no controls.
STEP 2
LET'S SEE AN EXAMPLE
For the embedded Flash Player
you should use this URL.
In this case you should replace
the Video ID
for the Video ID
you want to be seen.
Let's see an example
on YouTube Player Demo.
In this demo you can compare
the two types
of Flash Players.
STEP 3 -PROGRAM
THE CHROMELESS PLAYER
Not only can we program
and control the Flash Player
through Actionscript
from a Flash application,
we can also use the player
from a Flash application
through JavaScript.
To enable this possibility,
we should add a parameter
that enables JavaScript
in the player URL.
This URL will look like this.
In this introduction
to the Flash Player API,
we will not see how to use
the Actionscript API in detail.
Instead, we will see
how to control it in detail,
through the JavaScript API that,
with small differences,
is the same way to do it
as in the iFrame API.
I invite you to study in detail
the Actionscript API,
to download the examples,
to install the Flex SDK
Open Source
and to try to personalize
the behavior
and the way
the Flash Player is seen.
When should we use
the Flash and Actionscript API?
When your player is part
of a user experience
or an application developed
in Flash.
If this is not the case,
you should try to use
the iFrame Player
with the following parameters.
In this way, your user
experience or your application
will be compatible with
a greater number of platforms.
THE JAVASCRIPT API
The JavaScript API
will allow you
to control the Flash Player,
embedded or Chromeless,
through JavaScript.
You will be able to play videos,
pause them, stop them,
forward them to a certain point
or many other useful functions.
The page that the JavaScript
API uses should implement
the function
onYouTubePlayerReady.
This function will call
when the player is downloaded
and when the player
is ready to receive calls.
To develop a web application
or user experience
on a web page,
you should have a site
running on a web server.
This is due to restrictions
that exist in Flash
to communicate between local
and Internet files.
I also recommend using
SWF Object
to embed the player
that you then want to control
through JavaScript.
This library will allow you
to detect the Flash version.
Remember that you should
include the parameter
to control the player
through JavaScript.
We are going to create
a YouTube Flash Player
and we are going to its events
and control its behavior,
and all through JavaScript.
STEP 1
ENABLE JAVASCRIPT
Because the player downloads
from a different dominion
than the HTML page,
it's necessary to add
the allowScriptAccess parameter,
so that the SWF Player can call
the JavaScript functions
defined on the HTML page.
}STEP 2
READY THE PLAYER
Once the player
is loaded and ready,
the player will call the
function onYouTubePlayerReady.
In this function you can use
getElementById
to obtain a player reference
and start using the API.
STEP 3
CONTROL THE PLAYER
You can make a simple call
to control the player,
like play, for example.
STEP 4
MONITOR STATE CHANGES
Finally, you can subscribe
to the events and monitor
player state changes.
Add an EventListener
to onStateChange
and include
a call back function.
Before looking at real cases
where the APIs are applied,
and that we saw in this lesson,
let's look at a small comparison
between the JavaScript
and the API iFrameAPIs,
that also has JavaScript,
but that, in this case
is for the player
embedded in an iFrame.
Let's compare the format.
We see that for the iFrame API
the library downloads
asynchronously.
And once it loads
it allows us to access
the players.
When we access them,
we can specify
the parameters
to personalize them
or add functions
to manage its events.
On the right we see
that the old JavaScript API
that, through SWF Object,
allows access to
a Chromeless Player
and register EventListener
to manage the events.
I invite you, as homework,
to consult this excellent
Google presentation I/O 2011
to see more details
on this comparison.
A LOOK AT REAL CASES
Now let's see how the APIs
we saw in this lesson
are used in real cases.
AXE EXPERIENCE
Let's look at Axe Experience.
Let's look at the example
for a few moments.
In this case,
the player is used
in a larger Flash application.
So we see a case
where its better to use
the Flash API.
We also see that, to achieve
a totally personalized
user experience,
they have developed
their own controls,
and that the application
controls the player.
Have you figured out
how they did it?
I'm sure you did.
They used
the Actionscript Flash API
and the Chromeless Player.
KNORR MスICO
Let's look at Knorr M支ico.
After seeing this example,
we would think
that they are using
the Flash API.
But if we look
at the coding source
we see that it's an iFrame API.
Let's look at part of the coding
source for the page.
NISSAN MスICO
Let's look at one more case;
Nissan M支ico.
This is an excellent
user experience.
After inspecting the code,
we see they use the iFrame API.
Personalized through parameters
where the controls are hidden,
achieving an aspect similar to
the Flash Chromeless Player,
and they control it
through JavaScript.
I invite you to study
this official example.
You will be able to create
examples like the ones we saw.
I leave you with a challenge:
Try updating from
the Data API version 2
to the API version 3.
I hope you enjoyed this lesson.
We saw the basic ways
of how to use
the iFrame Player,
Flash and JavaScript APIs.
I invite you to study these APIs
more in depth.
You can experiment
with the official examples.
We have seen how to use
these APIs in real examples.
You can look for more cases,
and explore and analyze
how they are implemented.
See you the next lesson!